- If you hold a ball up
in the air and let it go,
you know it's going to fall, but why?
Nothing is touching it once you let it go.
How can there be a force on it?
Well, this is because
Earth's gravitational force
is pulling the ball and
gravity is a non-contact force.
Non-contact forces don't
have to touch an object
to exert a force on it.
Instead, these forces act over a region.
So if an object is in that region,
it will be affected by the force.
In this case, the ball is in
Earth's gravitational field,
and so it feels an attractive
force towards the Earth
and the ball falls to the ground.
Field forces include non-contact forces,
such as electric, magnetic,
and of course, gravitational forces.
So since these forces are non-contact,
they can exert a force on
objects they aren't touching,
but how do these objects know
if there's a force between them?
To explain these non-contact forces,
scientists eventually developed the idea
that these objects were
surrounded by something
called a field.
So what is a field?
A field extends through
space from an object
with certain physical properties.
What are those?
Well, for gravitational forces,
these affect objects with mass.
So any object with mass
has a gravitational field
surrounding it that points
towards the object's center.
The further you move away from the object,
the less dense the field and
weaker the field becomes.
Electric forces effect charged objects.
So an electric field surrounds
any object with a net charge,
and the direction of this field
will depend on the charge.
Magnetic fields will affect magnets
and any other material
with magnetic properties.
Each spot on a field has two
things associated with it:
magnitude and direction.
And these help us predict
what forces objects will experience
when they're in the field.
So let's look at an example
to help understand this.
Say we have a planet.
Now, the planet has a lot of mass
so we know it's going to be surrounded
by a gravitational field
that points towards the
center of the planet.
I can draw these little field lines
that show the direction of
the field and its strength.
As we move away from the planet,
the field will start to weaken,
and I'm going to represent
that by a less dense field
with these arrows.
Now, let's say there's an asteroid
moving near the planet in this direction.
I know that the asteroid,
as it's shown here,
is in the outskirts of this
planet's gravitational field.
So it is going to feel some
gravitational attraction
towards the planet,
which we can draw with this vector, Fg,
which is force of gravity.
Now, because it's attracted to the planet,
the astroid will continue
to move towards the planet.
And the closer the asteroid
gets to the planet,
the stronger the field
and the stronger the force
of attraction it will feel.
And so in this way,
scientists can use fields
to help predict behavior of objects
experiencing non-contact forces.
And all of this may sound kind of odd,
but you probably already
think about forces this way.
For example, if we go back to the ball
that you know is going to fall,
you knew this because the
force of gravity from Earth
was going to pull the
ball towards the Earth.
But now you also know that that's because
Earth's gravity is a field force.
And so the ball is in the
field of gravity for Earth
and experiences an attractive
gravitational force.
So while fields may sound mysterious,
they really just mean that a
force is felt over a distance.
Gravitational, electric,
and magnetic forces
are all field forces,
which means they act over distance
and can affect a lot of objects.